حاليا من الجدل الواسع عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تشرق بمصر وسبب منشورات بتدعي
الشباب المصري للزواج وبسرعه القصه وما
فيها انه صار في تداوله منشورات تابعه
لماذون ماذون انكحايه الشباب للزواج قبل
صدور قانون احوال الاسره الجديده الماذون
طلب الشباب بالزواج بشكل عاجل حتى لا
يدفعوا 30,000 جنيه لصندوق دعم الاسره الا
انه الايثار ما كان حدا يتوقعوا عموما
وزاره العدل ما سكته تبعت المنشورات
وتوصلت انه بعض هذه المنشورات تابعه
للماذون الشرعي محمد درويش مصطفى ولا
مساعده ياسر القرشي اللي كان يكتب بعض
المنشورات وينشر صور اقدام الماذون على
توفيق عقود زواج الموضوع اكيد ما خلص هون
في وزاره العدل حاله واقعه الماذون لان
النيابه العامه لتولى التحقيق والتهمه نشر
رسائل غير حقيقيه بتحمل شائعات مغرضه
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي يا جماعه
المصريين ما صدقوها كلمه من وقت ما طلع
القرار انتشرت منشورات وتغريدات سخريه
وتهكم بشكل كبير خلونا نشوف بعضها